[Music]
I have with me Mike Makai of Openreach
who's just presented at the FTTH
conference here in Amsterdam Mike nice
to talk to you again one of the things
you were talking about was open reach a
lots happened in the last 12 months yes
in the last 12 months we finished the
separation of open reach from BT as per
the agreement that BT reached with Ofcom
during 2017 the last major milestone
that we achieved was the transfer over a
thirty-one thousand employees to the
newly formed open reach limited from
from BT itself was the biggest 2p
transfer of people that's ever been
undertaken in the UK to the best of our
knowledge so it's a really big deal so
we feel now that we are fully
independent to the degree that's been
agreed between Ofcom and BT we started
to have a very different approach to the
way in which we talk with our customers
with our stakeholders we feel that we're
more engaged with them and we have
developed I think and recovered a lot of
the trust and so forth but it's very
necessary with with you know with one's
customers so we're very satisfied with
the progress that we've made and we've
done all that at the same time as
improving the service that we offer to
to our end customers and to our
customers in the marketplace and one of
the things you you asked for it in your
talk was a bit of help from the UK
government tell us a bit more about that
yeah that's right so we're fully
committed to be the you know the UK's
access network provider as we move into
the new world of fibre to the premises
and we've we made that announcement
about this time last year and we are
definitely on with that building at
spite pace and scale and we very much
want to provide the lion's share of the
government's ambitions which you may
recall by 2025 they want to have 15
million homes and businesses passed and
by 2033 they want to have the whole of
the UK fully Fiber those are very very
aggressive targets we're putting
together a business case at the moment
to help us you know support those those
targets and one of the areas where we
are looking for help from government is
in the
rateable value or the tax that they
charge on the network assets that we
build so at the moment there is a tax a
rate called cumulates which is applied
to all network assets as they are
actually built not when they become
revenue generating but as they are built
and clearly if you when you've got a
business case that takes 20 years to pay
back all the costs that you're paying
out before it starts to pay back you
know our are an impediment to actually
making the case to invest so what we've
asked government is that they consider
an exemption to all new fiber build for
a 20-year period from 2021 and and that
would significantly help us in terms of
improving our business case that we need
to take to our board and then take to
our shareholder bTW absolutely well
let's hope they'll be cheered by the
news that for the first time the UK is
in the global rankings you've played a
major part in that give us a reaction
I'm very very pleased that that's
happened I mean I think it was a bit of
an embarrassment that we weren't there
in the first place but here we are and I
think we will go from strength to
strength
you know we ourselves as you may have
heard me speak earlier we've doubled you
know our installed base of fiber in the
last 12 months which you know we built
more in the last 12 months than we had
built in the history of the company up
until that time and we will continue to
do that we are you know we're building
at a rate of about 14,000 that's a small
town in the UK 14,000 homes and
businesses a week at the moment and we
intend to continue to ramp that up so
that we can provide the lion's share of
the government's ambition that's
fantastic news Mike thank you very much
for talking to us thanks for your time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]